Dennis Rodman former Chicago Bulls
rebounding star has returned from a
five-day trip to North Korea he didn't
meet with Kim jong-un this time he did
previously describe Kim jong-un as a
friend for life he did give a North
Korean Minister a copy of Donald Trump's
art of the deal it's really weird he
signed a couple things jerseys and some
other items I'm having a hard time
identifying on video and one of the
gifts to a North Korean Minister was a
copy of Donald Trump's art of the deal
reportedly a signed copy Trump signed it
in crayon for Kim jong-un I'm kidding
about that part I'm not actually
reporting that it was a signed copy
Rodman oddly enough is the American with
really the most familiarity with North
Korean leader Kim jong-un it is bizarre
that that is the person in the United
States who is most familiar personally
with the leader of North Korea he didn't
speak to reporters waiting for him when
he arrived in Beijing after leaving
Pyongyang and Rodman has been pretty
heavily criticized for singing happy
birthday to Kim jong-un from a
basketball court during a 2014 trip to
North Korea he was also angry and
apparently drunk during a TV interview
when he suggested that the American that
was then being imprisoned in North Korea
deserved his punishment and then there's
also this really weird coincidence Pat
where within hours of Dennis Rodman
showing up in North Korea for this most
recent trip a college student who was
arrested in January of last year was
released now known to have been in a
coma for 14 year of I'm sorry 14 months
in North Korea State Department saying
it's coincidence they are not related
events in any way and here's where we
get to my conspiracy theory about all
this because of course Dennis Rodman
appeared on the Celebrity Apprentice
hosted by Donald Trump before of course
he was fired for misspelling Melania
Trump's name as we all know North so you
know maybe Trump send over Dennis Rodman
to North Korea as a way to make him an
agent and establish a back-channel yeah
my going off the rails here I think
you're totally off the rails
yeah yeah yeah everything is bizarre and
strange related to Dennis Rodman in
North Korea though Dennis Rodman did
make a statement about this but take a
listen to the political analysis from
from Dennis Rodman small country and
that's me you're always changing wrong
but you guys come back in kind of your
mettle as a lot of Korean people don't
really take note of it so Sue's about
force or anything like that now the wet
hand interviews over say is devolved and
twisting the city people so you see that
because there's a change and you got
intuitive about what's going on this was
close life yeah very solid political
analysis by the way of North Korea there
I over the weekend because of all this I
rewatched
vices the Hermit Kingdom episode where
Dennis rather than in a few Harlem
Globetrotters go to North Korea for
so-called basketball diplomacy and my
favorite scene is when they're taken to
a computer lab and it's dead silent
because the computers aren't really on
the internet they basically have
screenshots of browsers on the screens
yeah and there's one guy just looking at
google.com like he's reading it but
there's nothing there other than a place
where you would type in your google
search and it's just bizarre it's like
they don't even realize how fake it all
looks if you actually know what the
internet looks like I mean you could
still use mspaint minesweeper right like
you could we're back in the 90s yeah you
absolutely could do that they did have
windows the biggest news from the trip
rodman didn't vomit and defecate in a
Pyong yang hotel like last time things
were sort of calm related to that it's
all very very surreal